Postmodern view is like the hobbs of
view in some sense,
except you want to replace the
individual with,
with,
with pyramids of,
of social organization,
so hierarchies of social organization
that are based on group identity,
um,
and the landscape in which those
pyramids exists is one of unbroken
enmity and inability to communicate.
So it's a very dark view as far as I'm
concerned and I think it's fundamentally
wrong and in many ways,
I mean it's right in that there are
groups of people and there is some
difficulty in communication between
them.
And that power is an element in the
formation of hierarchies,
but you can't reduce hierarchy or group
relationship to those premises.
It's too simplified because people also
cooperate.
We're also not groups.
Men,
we,
many of us belong to many groups,
so it's to the actual situation is far
too complex to reduce it to that degree,
to reduce it to that degree.
Even though you can come up with a good
explanatory story if you do so,
it doesn't capture the nuances and
they're not just nuances.
It doesn't capture the essence.
Now,
the thing is is that when you make the
presupposition that the reason that
hierarchies exist is because of power,
then essentially what you do is turn to
every hierarchy into a tyranny.
And so if you,
if there is a hierarchy,
then you assume it's a tyranny.
Well,
that's really the patriarchy.
The Patriarchy is hierarchy assumed as
tyranny,
and that's also just not true except in
pathological hierarchies.
So for example,
we know from the psychological
literature that the best predictors of
longterm life success,
our intelligence and conscientiousness
in western countries at least.
Well,
that's what you'd hope for it,
right?
More or less,
if you,
if you want to even just set up a
society,
even if you weren't particularly smart
or hard working,
you might want to set up a society where
intelligence and hard work,
we are good predictors of success
because then the people who were smart
and hardworking would produce a bunch of
things that you could have if you could
trade for them.
And of course that is actually the
situation that most of us are in.
So,
and of course the other thing about
people who believed that hierarchies in
the West are only composed of of power
and tyranny is that their own actions
belie that because whenever they make a
decision to interact with that
hierarchy,
they attempt or to make a purchase or or
to make a trade,
let's say,
or to obtain a service,
a service of any importance,
let's say a medical service,
they are going to definitely act as if
there are less and more competent people
within that hierarchy and seek out the
ones that are more competent obviously,
which you don't do if the.
If the hierarchy is only composed of
tyranny and power,
there's no point looking for.
But anyways,
in the west and in functioning
societies,
hierarchies are basically predicated on
competence and not power.
And and you might say,
well that's pretty naive.
It's like,
no,
actually it's not very naive.
I'm not saying at all that inappropriate
power plays don't play a role in
corrupting hierarchies of competence.
That happens,
but generally what happens is if the
hierarchies of competence get corrupted
enough by power,
then they crumble because they can no
longer function.
So,
and the,
you know,
the evidence that are hierarchies of
competence.
Work is everywhere because everything
around us works all the time ion hers.
The two interesting stories in her book,
infidel,
which is a great book by the way,
um,
she came from Africa and from a country
that wasn't very functional and when she
came to Holland she said there were two
things that really amazed her,
um,
and this really struck me because,
you know,
now,
and then you get lucky and you can see
the,
the world you live in from an outsider's
perspective,
right?
You get to see through someone else's
eyes.
Um,
she said the first thing that knocked
her off her feet was waiting for a bus
and in Amsterdam and on the,
you know,
she's standing at the bus stop and
there's a pole there and there's digital
sign on the pole and the digital sign
says when the next bus is going to come
and counts down.
And then when it hits zero,
the bus appears and she,
she just,
she absolutely could not believe that
that would happen,
that there could be a sign that told you
when the bus would come and that it
would change and the bus would actually
appear and you think,
well,
yeah,
no,
that's a miracle man.
That's an absolute miracle.
It is.
You got to think that through,
you know,
the amount of timing and organization
and,
and reliability,
mechanical reliability and sociological
or social organization and dedication on
the part of the bus drivers and the
entire company and the Organization of
the whole city and the state to make
that possible is absolutely beyond
belief,
especially when it's time to,
well perhaps not the second but to 10
seconds or something like that.
That is absolutely beyond belief and her
inability to comprehend.
That was the correct response.
And then the other things she was amazed
by was that you could go talk to
policemen and they would help you.
That was just,
that was just a no go for her because
for her,
her experience was policemen were there
to shake you down and and hurt you,
and so you think,
well,
you know,
I won't.
I won't dwell on that point any longer.
The point is,
is that it's absolutely ridiculous,
blind to make the assumption that the
hierarchies in functioning Western
democracies are fundamentally predicated
on power and tyranny.